دعي الصوره هي من تجيب على هذا السؤال هل
ترى تحسن على اوضاع النازحين المشردين
جراء الزلزال تشاهدينا الان
العائلات التي تفترس الارض لا خيمه لا
طعام لا دفء ما عندهم اي شيء سوى الارض
التي يفترشونها على جانب الطريق الرئيسي
الواصل بين البلدات في ريف حلب شمال غربي
سوريا
ليس عندهم ادنى مقومات للحياه هذه
العائلات هنا منذ عده ايام منذ ان دمرت
بيوتها
او منذ ان هربت عائلات اخرى ايضا من
بيوتها هربا وخوفا من الهزات الارتداديه
المستمره وهربا من الزلزال الذي ضرب
المنطقه عندهم الاطفال الذين موجودون هنا
النساء كثير
يعانون جراء هذا البرد وكثير منهم مرضى
نحن عاينا اوضاعهم قضينا معهم ساعات
وساعات طوال الايام الماضيه ولم تصلهم
المساعدات حتى الان هنالك عائلات ربما
وصلتها خيام لكن كثير من العائلات لم
تصلها المساعدات بعد ربما تشاهدون في
الصوره تلك الخيمه تلك الخيمه الوحيده
الجديده ممكن تصور هذيك الخيمه تلك الخيمه
الوحيده التي رايناها جديده في هذه
المنطقه اما بقيه العائلات هنا فلم تصلها
مساعدات حتى الان على الجانب الاخر من هذه
الصوره نشاهد هذه الخيام التي وصلت
للعائلات المشرده هذا هذا المخيم تماما
نحو 90 خيمه لا طبعا هذه ايضا من جهود
محليه ليست جهود امميه او هنا مساعدات
امميه بطبيعه الحال وصلت الى شمال غربي
سوريا لكن لم تصل تلك المساعدات الى قسم
كبير من العوائل المتضرره والتي تحتاج الى
المساعدات العاجله والطريقه